these parts
they all have funny names zambani zotes
zambiano zombieachi
[Music]
nepobot
and zambaru
so I thought it'd be cool to just try
and speedrun all these Bots
because the highest rate I bought
it starts at 400s on bani zotes is 800.
all the way to Hikaru who's only 1800
and I'll start with the weakest which is
zambani
and we'll see how this goes
so zombie chest speed run
starting now okay zambani will be the
first victim hopefully he doesn't bite
me
we're doing no assistance of any kind
and here we go so I want to play as like
as aggressively as possible
he's only rated 400 but he's playing
like a top GM level right now that's
like Mainline opening Theory what is
this
why is he playing Mainline opening
theory if he's rated 400
okay Queen E7 I think is the first
non-book move
okay
oh no Vox Queen
um yeah I just want to win quickly
the the key to taking down the Bots
especially quickly he says no stay away
I can't help myself though
oh it's really close to mating
I'll save the bishop this is almost meat
but the Knight defended
okay it's gonna be made very very soon
The Rook will come in
start with the queen
there we go
oh no my queen someone call an ambulance
he says yum almost a tasty almost as
tasty as greens
but more tasty for me okay
uh that was a nice start
next spot
playing zotes let's play a London
this is this is botes's like main
opening
at least Andrea botez
I think Alexandra sometimes plays this
too
okay free night
I'm about two minutes in right now
no mercy
oh we're not going to see a zotes Gambit
unfortunately we already traded Queens
I'm playing 95.
yeah key strategy is just to take as
many free things as possible
and then eventually go for the mating
attack
if Knight takes I've Rook d8
there we go
oh mercy
this Bishop's just stuck the bishop has
new legal moves
where's my mate
where's my mate
where's my mate
okay we got a pawn mate
let's go three minutes in next spot
playing zombiano a zombie I'm gonna play
the Stafford
let's play a Halloween Gavin against
zombiano
happy Halloween
oh okay let's play F4 guaranteed to Fork
as a funny line
so I already won a piece
okay this is a beautiful looking
position
already let's play Queen H5
setting up E5 and queen H7 is now a
threat
wow zambiano is the easiest spot so far
13 moves
moving on to zombiachi
I think rated 1600 no rated 1400.
it's help helping to be white in every
game I don't know if the colors are
randomized
oh this is a funny Gambit
reminds me of of what getting bitten
uh what do I do
I want to do some funny Checkmate let's
play Knight C3 first
okay I might be threading this
or maybe this
oh okay this is very tasty
did I select white only okay I guess I'm
uh
I'm getting some small Edge then
no mercy
no mercy
that's me than three
oh no it's not me than three
oops I thought it was mating by force
I'm still up some pawns though
yeah
check check
out where's the meat
if I take on F7
where's my duck
I'll just play this first
okay it's really close to meat
I got The Rook battery
okay I'm winning the knights
oh no I pre-move the wrong move
is zombie actually gonna eat me
that was such a bad pre-move
I have to come back now
don't hurt me
objectively this is maybe drawn
and I'm still gonna push for a win
though
E6
I think I'm still winning like barely
okay King is extra safe here
he says 40 moves brains what does that
mean
he's just moving his Rook back and forth
um if I push
um
where's my win
okay so I'm hitting the Rook from the
distance with the bishop
now I have this move
okay both Rooks are hit
here we go
okay I'm guaranteed to Queen
let's go
no funny sailmate traps
oh no
wait if I take the Rook it's stalemate
I just said no funny sailing traps
stop it
wait how did I do this
this is really annoying ah it's still
still made
take the queen please
yes okay
oh
this is such a long game
okay I'll just take
let's go
okay I'm about nine minutes in
final bot this is a final boss zambaru
let's not mess up
oh it's a Dutch zombaru playing the
Dutch
okay let's play Let's play my usual not
quite a London oh let's play G4 okay
let's have some fun
G5
this is actually a line I studied before
I prefer this a while ago um against
Augustine
it's a funny line
I think I'm supposed to play this
Knight C3 ooh okay I'll accept the
gamuts G4
zambaru just saying stop this
okay
I'm a little bit scared that there's so
many open files for black
but I've consumed so many pawns that
uh oh
um
D5
wait what is this
I was ambarro being
slightly annoying here
okay I'll just go for castling
okay now there's some attacking
potential
D5
wait how do I Checkmate the king
okay let's just take on C7
so if takes I have this
play Rook B3
I'm up so many Pawns
I don't really care about that Rook
unless I do
I'll get back material I just want to
Castle my king
was this move
zambara is playing some crazy chess
I think it's all okay
have this
E4
there we go okay that was a keep on to
win
um
this move doesn't quite work
oh no
I just plundered a rook
oh no
King G2 Knight F4 I have to play this
I'm still alive though
somehow
but this is kind of vicious
H4 Maybe
how many pawns do I have
this
I might not win this just plundered a
rook
in this move
oh what to do a four
I think it's still okay
92's coming
in King H2
94
the E4 doesn't quite work
I'll play A4
and he's playing like a bot now
like a zombie I have this
ah the queen A5 is really annoying
no actually Queen A5 I take the Knight
so hit attacking defending
I play D7
and queen G3 first
I also have this move
really
so I have this
all right this has to be winning like
Queen
how is it winning
I was Queen C7 maybe Queen C7
threatening promotion
[Music]
I think it's winning
and now Queen C8
you just miss us
and you just misses
he says tasty
my opponent is playing wheel
under promotion for the maximum
humiliation
[Music]
okay
I took less than 15 minutes
okay zombie chess speedrun accomplished